make sure you watch this video to the
very end because you could be at risk of
becoming deregistered as an architect
seven years of education a lifetime
career and a portfolio of amazing work
could all be tarnished in the blink of
an eye in today's video we're talking
about the five do's and five do Nots of
architecture out of all of these don'ts
the second last one is the most serious
like Mike Ross jail time series if you
get the reference make sure you leave a
comment down below let's start with a
double header first of all make sure you
learn from your mistakes and don't
punish your clients as a result of those
mistakes let me give you some examples
first of all let's say you've priced the
job you've priced it accordingly what
you thought was fair and reasonable the
brief hasn't changed the scope hasn't
changed you've just blown budget
horrendously and a bleeding money left
right and Center most people would
somehow try to flip this narrative turn
around to their client and say look you
owe me more money for some reason in or
another all that's going to do is upset
your client leave them with a sour taste
in their mouth and then they're going to
tell the next person who asked them
about you that you just tried to get as
much money out of them as you could
regardless of how good your design was
so just take this young chin learn from
your mistake make sure it doesn't happen
again and be humble about the whole
experience if your client knows that you
aren't making money on that project that
might be fine but don't diminish that
project in any way shape or form because
of it you have to remember that
architecture is a lifelong career you're
going to minute for a very very long
time and people's opinions matter so
when you do something wrong by somebody
else you're going to make an enemy out
of them pretty quickly your clients are
actually going to be your best marketing
it doesn't matter how good of a social
media marketer you are your clients Word
of Mouth means more than any social
media targeted ad so if you can keep
your clients happy even if you make
mistakes along the way mistakes happen
they need to be rectified then to be
fixed obviously but keep them happy and
all will end up working okay in the long
run the second do on this list is make
sure you hire as soon as you need the
help if you need the help don't be a
cheapskate make sure you go out and hire
somebody suitable for your position you
want to make sure to hire the best
possible candidate If this means they're
going to cost you a little bit more
money it is going to be worth it in the
long run you don't want to save yourself
a couple hundred dollars a couple
thousand dollars whatever that number
might be to Simply hurt yourself in the
long run and most likely pay somebody to
do a subpar job that you could do 10
times quicker and it isn't even worth
paying them at all and on that note
don't let your clients down because
you're too cheap to hire somebody if you
are so busy it doesn't give you any
right to drag out clients projects
forever most architects who are running
sole practitioner offices will take on
as much work as possible because they
know when times are tough they're tough
and they know when time times are good
they're good but what they don't realize
is times are good because the clients
have talked about them they've said
great things about them and times are
tough for the exact opposite reasons
clients have said bad things about them
they've been let down they've been
disappointed so if you are running a
solo practice make sure you hire
somebody so your clients don't end up
saying bad things about you because you
disappointed them you didn't email them
back you didn't call them and you just
in general let them down third on the do
list is actually spend time on your
business not just in your business so
what do I mean by that spending time on
your business means understanding the
fundamentals of it improving the
workflow improving the processes and
making sure that more people come in the
door so let's say you're manually
filling out time sheets spend some time
figure out how you can automate the
system how you can get an online
timesheet system to be able to save
yourself a significant time and at the
same time justify your work if you need
to go out and find more clients to bring
more work in make sure you do it go to
those networking events speak to those
Builders speak to the people you haven't
spoken to in months even though this may
seem like an utter waste of time isn't a
billable activity at the end of the day
there is going to be no billable
activities if you completely forget
about working on your business and not
just in your business now if you're
still thinking what do you mean by
working just in your business well don't
only work in your business working in
your business means spending a hundred
percent of your time focusing on all of
your current clients all of your current
work all of your current Billings and
everything that is currently billable
and does not expand beyond that yes that
is fantastic it drives the work in and
yes it has to be done however there
should be some sort of ratio between
billable non-billable or in and on your
business that is going to allow you to
both Excel that business and operate
that business as best as possible so as
an architect make sure that you spend
time on and in your business now all of
these do's and don'ts are pretty serious
but the second last don't is the one
that you need to pay attention to
because it could get you deregistered
the last don't is pretty serious it'll
probably get you killed however we're
going to stick to the fourth do first
and then work our way into the serious
stuff for the fourth do you need to have
the tough conversations these
conversations aren't going to be
something that you want to get out of
bed and do they're not going to be
something that you're genuinely
passionate about if you are good for you
it definitely isn't me I don't enjoy
having these tough conversations but I
know they have to happen now the last
don't revolves around money you do not
want to be anybody's personal bank now
you might not think you will have to be
anybody's personal banker as an
architect but the reality is you need a
cash flow your life your business and
people end up relying on you to do that
for them as well as a very typical
example most Builders expect a 30-day
account that means you have to produce
work for 30 days you get paid at the end
of the 30 days those terms and
conditions are pretty standard industry
wide but there is a limit to them you do
not want to be doing work for months and
months and months on end for free never
getting paid that Builder going bankrupt
you being so far in the red that you
don't have any money to pay your bills
your creditors your clients or even your
staff that puts you in the bad books of
everybody besides from quickly going
bankrupt from owing people too much
money you could very easily become
deregistered for things that you have to
do as a result of losing this exorbitant
amount of money which quickly brings me
on to point number five which is just
the serious as Point number four don't
break any laws in your personal life in
your work life it does not matter I'll
give you an example There Was An
Architect here in Western Australia that
unfortunately got drunk got behind the
wheel of a car hit somebody this is a
criminal offense in Australia most
likely a criminal offense everywhere
around the world now did this architect
conduct malicious malpractice did he do
anything that would tarnish his
reputation as an architect and his
abilities as an architect well no
technically he could still draw and
design as well as he always could but
the board decided that his ethical
Behavior around his personal life wasn't
something that they wanted to justify
and put the title architect against
because it is a registered protected
Title Here in Australia so this crime
from a personal standing Point not a
professional one still led to this man
being deregistered so you do not want to
do anything illegal be it in your
personal life or in your professional
life because both could get you
de-registered and I think we should end
on a bit more of a happy note make sure
you do educate yourself constantly and
continuously you need to be educating
yourself obviously on all things
architecture but you want to be
educating yourself on laws and
regulations as they change here in
Australia they're rapidly changing every
couple of years there's a new
construction code every couple of months
there's a new regulation or a new law so
if you aren't constantly paying
attention continuously learning
continuously researching which takes an
absorbitant amount of time that you
can't bill for you will end up in deep
trouble so make sure you keep learning
and improving yourself every single day
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed the video make sure you check
out the playlist to the side of me if
you love the video make sure you smash
that subscribe button down below and
like always I'll see you next Monday